Our
next presenter is the creator of Open
Claw, the world's fastest growing
open-source AI. He recently joined
OpenAI to work on bringing agents to
everyone. Please join me in welcoming to
the stage Peter Steinberger.
Good morning everyone.
So, Swiss asked me to do a state of the
claw. Who here is running open claw?
Give me some hands.
Ah, it's like 30 40%. Very good. Um,
yeah,
it's been quite a few months. Um, the
project is now five months old.
I think it's fair to say by now that we
are the fastest growing project in
GitHub's history. Um, if you've seen the
the graph, usually it's some some
projects look like a hockey stick, but
ours was just like a straight line and a
friend called it stripper pole gross
and that comes with its own challenges.
So, we have I think now we are the the
largest number on GitHub stars. There's
a few that are bigger but they're
basically educational target. No other
software project is that big. It's
around 30,000 commits. It we're closing
in 2,000 contributors
soon to be 30,000 PRs. Um,
see, and we're not slowing down. So, you
see that it's a ramp, but you know, it's
we only have April 9. So, um,
velocity keeps keeps being good.
And at the same time,
it hasn't been easy. You know, I I had
two roads when I when I decided what I
want to do and I I did the whole company
thing. I was like, I don't want to do
this again. And then I joined OpenI, but
then we also created the Open Cloud
Foundation. And now I kind of have two
jobs.
And running the foundation is like a
running a company on hard mode because
you have like all the all the things
that you need to take care of but also
you have a lot of volunteers that you
can't really direct.
So
one of my goals has been working on the
on the bus factor like who does comets.
Um and you see that it's slowly
improving.
Vincent's actually talking after me but
we're still not we're still not there.
Um, in the last months I I talked to a
lot of companies.
So we now have people from Nvidia on
board. We have someone from Microsoft on
board to like help with MS Teams with
like a Windows app. Uh, we have someone
from Red Hat who's really helping us um
with security and dockerization. We work
with a lot of Chinese companies. We have
people from from Tencent and Biteance.
um they're actually much larger users
than any other continent
and yeah people from pretty much around
the world but like the main thing I I
want to like talk a little bit about is
about open claw is so insecure you know
you've you've seen the
you've seen the memes like open claw
invites the bad guys
and you probably also seen
companies like Nvidia
doing Nemo claw and like everyone has
little lobsters.
So
you also notice that like in the last
two three months there's been a lot of
releases where things broke.
I've basically been been dodoed by
security advisories. So that's what I
did um and what I focused on. So far we
got 1,142
advisories. That's around 16.6 a day. 99
are critical. Um we published around 469
and we closed 60% of them. So these
numbers sound like absolutely
terrifying.
If you compare it for example to like
other large projects like the Linux
kernel gets like eight or nine a day. we
get like twice as much and curl so far
has 600 reports we have like twice as
much as curl.
So every time I I get a
security incident, the rule is the
higher the higher they screaming how
critical they are, the more likely it's
slop. Like we we I mean you've probably
also seen the news like we we we are
very fast moving into a world where
we have to change how we build software
because all these AI tools are getting
so good at identifying
even the most weird multi-chained
exploits and like we're gonna going to
break all the software that exists. I
give you an example like
uh Nvidia they
they launched Neimoclaw and Neimoclaw is
a a plug-in and a security layer for
open claw. You can put it in a sandbox.
I the keynote was on Monday. They
invited me on Sunday to like work with
them. I hooked it up to Codex security.
It found like five different ways how to
break out of the of their secure sandbox
within half an hour.
That's because like if you use that
product, you get access to the unnerved
model that is quite a bit smarter in
terms of cyber than what the public has
access. Exactly. Because it's dangerous.
But yeah um
also this whole industry those people
for them it's like credits right the
more the more issues they find the more
they seen so like openclaw was like the
insecure product that everybody tried to
break so literally like hundreds of
people firing up their clankers trying
to break open claw
um
the typical attack surface is like
remote code execution,
bypass approval, code injection, pass
traversal. Uh again sounds all very
dangerous
and I give you I give you one one
concrete example. Um
Gshjp.
This is about a this is a CVSS of 10. So
it's like the scariest thing that you
can possibly do.
It is an issue where if you
uh sync for example the iPhone app that
we haven't even shipped yet but is in
progress and you give it only read
permission then you could like break the
system to also get write permission.
So this this one was so critical that
the I know this one's actually different
one
in all in all practical ways
it is not even an incident because the
the the typical use cases you install it
on your machine
either in a cloud or if you have to on a
Mac mini I stopped fighting this I'm
just letting people have fun now
but in 99% 99% cases you'll either have
access to your gateway or you have not
access to the gateway. In in in my
defense, this was my mistake that I
tried to create a a more permissive
model. For example, if you have devices
that would target speech and then would
only like read certain things. So
there's like some use case where you
could like have a a reduced permission
system would make sense.
Um but nobody's even using that. But
this doesn't matter because the rules of
the of those how you create the CVSS
numbers don't contribute to that at all.
And I try to play by the rules. So it is
a 10 out of 10. And the world is going
crazy over incidents that in all
practical ways will not affect people.
There's some other stuff that does
affect people. Uh we have nation states
trying to like hack people. There was
like ghost claw which is like from
likely from North Korea which is
basically
confusing people with a different NBN
package and if you if you go to a wrong
website and you try to download it you
get like a a root kit. Um that's outside
of our control. This happens for other
people as well. Um,
also there's the Axios thing which funny
enough we are not using Axios
but we are using MS teams or Slack as a
dependency and they're using XIS and
they didn't pin us and of course uh
because that's how supply chain attacks
work we were also affected.
Yeah. How do you survive 1,142? I'm sure
it's 1,150.
Uh for a while I I I tried to handle a
loop by myself and which is absolutely
impossible.
So So the fastest way to get help was
like getting getting help from companies
um and Nvidia has been really amazing to
like give us some people that basically
work full-time going through the slop
and hardening the code base.
Oh, there's also one that is
okay.
That um
this is one of the anglers. The other
angle is like there's a lot of companies
that do fearongering and it's not just
companies, it's also universities. I
don't know if you've seen it. There was
like this um
paper who made the rounds agents of
chaos and they say oh it's it's about
agents in general but then there's four
pages that explain the open claw
architecture in utmost detail
but you know which page they didn't even
mention
a security page where we explain how you
should install it because then it
wouldn't be fun then it wouldn't be it
would be hard to make a good story. So
what they instead did is they ignored
all of the recommendations we do on
security. Recommendation is it's your
personal agent. Don't put it in a group
chat. If you put it in a group chat,
turn on sandboxing because if anyone can
talk to your agent, they can excfiltrate
anything that the agent can do, right?
So if it's a team agent, it should only
know what the team can know and not any
secret data. And you probably want to
like have it restricted. If it's your
personal agent, you should be the only
one being able to talk to you. But if
you don't play by these rules, you can
get some really fun interactions like,
"Hey, I can talk to your agent and it
can break your system." And then because
I I was I was grilling them a little bit
because I had some questions how to do
things. They told me, "Oh yeah, no, we
run it in pseudo mode because we wanted
the agent to be like maximum powerful."
So they actually fought the setup. It's
actually not easy to run it in pudo
mode. You have to change code. um
but they didn't mention it in the report
because again that wouldn't give them
cloud.
So yeah um my current frustration is
like there's like a whole industry that
try to put the project in negative
light. It's a nightmare.
It's insecure by default. It's
unacceptable.
Um
and meanwhile a lot of people love it
and people who actually
read the security docs understand it can
use it just fine. One example that I
found particularly great is u we had one
remote one rce that panicked Belgium.
So the Belgium cyber security did a
release uh about a remote execution
environment
and the whole bug was
a feature where a malicious website
could create a link
that would
trigger the gateway and then forward
your gateway token. Now if you use the
setup that is the default and that is
recommended the gateway token is local
only or if you have to it's in your
private network no external website can
actually access it. If you
actively fight the setup and for example
use cloud code to set it up without
reading, you might be able to get this
setup working.
But again,
that's not anything what's said on the
website.
So to be very honest, yes, there's
absolutely
uh risk. the the the big risk is the the
basically the legal trifecta. You know,
any any agentic system that has access
to your data,
has access to untrusted content and the
ability to communicate is something
that's potentially at risk. That's not
anything special to OpenClaw. It's like
any any agent any power agent system has
a problem. The more the more powerful
you make it, the more it can do for you,
but the more you also have to understand
what it does. So this is like the the
main issue
>> but people not talk about this. Yeah.
And then also
um
some part about maintaining.
So
the problem is like if you get all those
security advisories,
you know that most of them are created
with agents, but you still have to use
your brain to actually read it because
we're not at the point where you can
fully trust or I'm not at the point
where I I can just fully trust that the
agent will figure it out. So it is a
huge burden on on time and you never
know. I mean sometimes you can you can
often guess you know anytime the reput
is too nice or like someone apologizes
that's very likely AI because usually
people in security don't apologize. Um
but it is a huge problem and it's
something that I see more and more open
source projects complaining about or
like breaking. Um,
some are very public about it like
ffmpeg.
Usually you get the report. It's very
rare that you actually get a report and
a fix. If you get a report and a fix,
it's usually a very bad fix. If you rush
it, as I sometimes did in the beginning
because I was overload, you will very
certainly break your product.
Yeah. So this is something that's just
very difficult to pull up only with
volunteers. So we so
what are we working on?
Number one is
I
people say like open AI bought open claw
that's not the truth. they might bought
my soul.md
um but they very much understand that in
order for what the world needs is like
more people that play with AI to like
understand what AI can do to both
understand the risk and also the
possibilities they understand that if
you or like someone who never played
with never used AI suddenly is at home
and uses openclaw they'll come to work
and they will ask why don't we have AI
at work so they very much understand
that like supporting this project is
very useful and in order for that
project to be successful cannot be under
one company. Therefore, I'm kind of
building Switzerland with the open glove
foundation and I have Dave was helping
me with it. Um, it's almost done. The
last thing that's keeping us going is
like the American bank system which is a
little bit slow and very confused when
you're not American.
Um, it's inspired by what Ghosti did.
And this will actually then help us to
hire full-time people to both keep up
the pace, improve the quality, and free
up some of my time that I can work on on
cool stuff again.
And that's my little update on State of
the Claw. I'll be around later for like
a Q&A. Thank you for listening.
Okay,
great. Thank you for the whoop. Love the
whoop. Um, so excellent. Okay, you've
chosen the claw uh track to get started
on for our our breakouts and uh uh it's
going to be great. I think it's going to
be it's going to be a good session. Um
we are going to be hearing about a bunch
of different things uh related to uh
openclaw and just personal AI assistance
in general. There's some open claw
contributors, openclaw maintainers, uh
um uh open claw competitors, uh and open
claw creators, uh going to be here on
the stage. Um we're actually going to uh
be taking this through until the lunch
break. Um oh, there we go. We can see up
there. So, it's about an hour and a half
of uh of sessions, slightly shorter
sessions than uh than earlier, I think.
Um but we're going to be starting with
uh an AMA. came in. You saw Peter
earlier on, but you're going to get a
chance to ask questions and there's
going to be a bit of a conversation uh
with Peter and Swix. So, I think to get
us started, I will simply invite Swix up
who will kick things off. So, uh please
welcome him to the stage. Swix, come on
up. Swix.
>> All right.
>> Actually, you can just go together.
>> You can come out together. There's no
secret. Peter, welcome. Everybody there
is
Okay, so the deal for this is meant to
be an AMA. Uh the the main idea is that
I've run six of these AI engineers and
whenever we have some big maintainer,
big VIP, we only give them a talk, but
actually you guys have questions that
you want to ask. Uh so uh we wanted to
sort of create that opportunity. So you
can you can submit there. I'm going to
moderate uh and and all that. Uh the
spicy one I'm just going to start off
with. Pete just quote uh quote tweeted
uh me and saying send all your questions
about closed claw right uh
I think uh people have a lot of
questions about um the future of
openclaw at openai uh and uh I wanted to
give you the space what what is the what
are people saying about closed claw and
then what is your response
>> I didn't even think about it was like it
came up when when I decided to go to to
openi And
I think I think people have a point that
open air wasn't always
amazing with open source. And I I think
a lot changed like Codex is open source
now. They released Symfony which is a
really cool orchestration layer. So like
like they're really leaning in and
understanding open source now. They
understand that open cloud needs to stay
open work with any model be it be it one
of the the big companies or being a
local model um everybody in the industry
wins if more people spend time with AI
you know if if I if I think AI is
something scary and then suddenly I I I
play with open claw and suddenly it's
like fun and weird and then I come to
work and there's no like I don't have AI
tools at work. I'm going to get to my
boss and say why the f do we not have AI
at work and and then like those
companies would probably not run open
claw but we want something that's like
hosted and managed and and then somebody
can can make a sale. So they they're
like very much on board. They provide me
with resources. Um, actually it's me
like I could get a lot more people from
OpenAI to help with the project, but
that would just make a picture that they
could have taken over the project and I
don't want that. So I I I brought in
people from Nvidia, we have someone from
Microsoft, from Telegram, someone from
Salesforce of all the companies. So So
shout out actually there's cool people
at Slack. So we have someone that
maintains the Slack plugin. Now I
brought Tensent on board, Bite Dance. We
talked to Alibaba, Miniax, Kimi, like
all the all the model providers. They're
like very much on board. Um, Nvidia has
been immensely helpful. They
I think I one of the coolest companies
in terms of here's some engineers who
actually like just hire agency and just
do things.
>> Yeah. Uh and now that I have all the
other companies, I'm also bringing a few
people in from OpenAI to to help
maintain the project because it's I mean
software is just like changing that the
the pace at which this project operates
is is insane. You kind of like you need
an army. Um and I'm working on that.
>> You have an army. Uh and but but you
know even the contributor chart that you
showed uh shows that it's hard to get
quality contributors to stick around.
people keep hiring your maintainers and
then you have to find new ones. Um so
there's a lot of questions about local
models and open models. Uh you know like
not every part of the stack is open.
There's many models where you don't have
access to the models and and you know
there's sort of weird restrictions. Um
how important is open and local models
to the future openclaw? I mean part of
part of what what motivated me to build
open claw is you see all these large
companies and then they have connectors
to my Gmail and then my my email is
hosted somewhere then this company has
full access to my email and then I can
get a little bit down there like it's
much more exciting to me if I have all
my data actually under my control and I
and like a little bit of it goes up
there if I need the top tier token.
>> Yeah. and like a second kind of
hierarchy of uh fallback models.
>> Yeah, you want to I mean I'm I'm
European at heart. You want to own your
data, you know. So so so and nobody
built it. So for me that was very
attractive and also the the fact that
you know if if you're a startup you want
to connect to Gmail, it takes like half
a year and it's like a very very
difficult process. But if I'm a consumer
my clanker can click on any website and
it happily clicks on I'm not a bot. If
you have to give me the data somehow, if
you can if you give me the data, my my
agent is able to get the data. So you
can work around a lot of those those
silos those big companies are building
and ultimately you can do much cooler
automation use cases that large
companies can never do.
>> So it's it's like
it's a little bit the the hacker way.
>> Yeah. And um any indications from the
open team on GBTOSS? Is that continu
continuing to be a stream of work that
uh will be aligned with open claw or or
is that like separate?
>> I'm not I'm not in a position to give
yeah
>> give you insights on that just that
um part of what opencloud triggered is
that like more people in the company are
getting excited about open source. Um,
and I I love that that OpenAI is moving
more into the open direction. Again, if
you compare it to some other top tier
labs that start with an A, uh, that very
much will sue you if you if you leak any
of their source um, or block you if you
are too successful. I I I think Open is
on a good direction.
>> Yeah. Okay. I want to highlight this
question. Um, people love hearing about
your coding workflow. I think right by
now your idea of um uh the prompt
request rather than the pull request is
is very well socialized and also you've
been shocking people with just how
you're spending tokens at OpenAI.
Uh so basically uh the people want to
know how you ship and what do you do
about agent waiting times like why is
you know you're spinning out so many
agents. I
>> I know like I I never imagined that this
one picture of me would blow up so much.
>> Yeah. actually
>> uh give give some numbers just just to
align people. I I think and there's
times where I was running almost 10
sessions at the same time especially
when I used codeex with 50 51 it was
quite slow I think now I have to say we
it's still weird we made improvements
they both make it faster and then
there's also fast mode so by now my
typical workflow is
maybe half of that maybe five six
windows instead of double just because
each loop is faster and like the
area of work I sync in workers is pretty
much the same. So I I don't have to use
split screen so much anymore and I think
we're going to move into a future where
um
token will be will be faster and faster.
So at some point like this is not
natural that you work on on six things
at the same time. Um
but it's basically a workaround until
until faster. Yeah. Uh, one of my, uh,
interesting things of putting you next
to Ryan was to see how the two of you
kind of approach uh, token maxing.
Basically, I'm curious what you think
about the the complete dark factory
approach, right? That uh, you don't even
review code that goes in.
I think that's more and more doable.
But also, you know, when I when I
dark factory in a way also means I come
up with everything I want to build in
the beginning and I just don't think you
can build good software in that way.
Like
the way to the mountain is usually never
a straight line. It is it is it is very
curved. Sometimes you go a little bit
off track and then you you see something
new that inspires you. You find like
shortcuts. Um
once you're at the top you you you can
find the optimal path but you never walk
like this. So at the same time you will
the first idea that you have about your
project is very unlikely going to be the
final project. But if I if I suddenly
use the waterfall model again that will
be the final project. For me that
doesn't work for me. Like I I build
steps I play with it. I see how it
feels. I get new ideas, my prompts
change. So to me, it's a very iterative
approach. So I don't see how you could
fully automate that. You can definitely
build pipelines for certain things.
>> Yeah.
>> But even even for PRs, you don't just
want to build a pipeline that just
merges PRs because a lot of them just
don't make sense, you know, like people
people will pull your product into all
kind of directions. But if you automate
that, the AI will very unlikely know
what's the right direction. You can
guide it. I have like a vision document
that I tried some of that but
the bottleneck is still sinking and like
having taste.
Yeah, taste is very important. Uh how do
you define taste? This is something that
in my conversations with people everyone
understands taste is the moat but nobody
agrees on what taste good taste is. So
I'm just curious to hear yours. I think
in this day and age is like
the very low level of taste if if it
doesn't stink like AI and you know
exactly what I mean you know if if
something is just so writing style
personality
>> also also also UI by now you've seen so
many so much aentic built UI that you
immediately know if it's AI
>> yeah if it has the the color border on
the left right
>> yeah I mean for a while it was like the
purple gradient but much more so I I
feel It's it's like a feeling the same
as you can identify AI written slop
right away.
>> Yeah.
>> Um that's why I say it's a smell. Like
even if you can pinpoint this, you will
know. So So that's probably the lowest
the lowest characterization of taste.
And and then going higher up because now
so much of software is is automatable.
There's actually much more time you can
spend on like the little details. I
don't know, you know, like like just
when you when you when you when you run
open claw, you get like a little message
uh that sometimes roasts people.
Those are like the delightful details I
think that
>> you'll just not get if you prompt in a
high level.
>> Yeah. One one of my favorite tastes of
yours is how you you uh really put a lot
of work into your soul soulm and you uh
you know open source your approach and I
don't think people worked on enough soul
until until you came along. So I think
that's really interesting. Uh my I I I
have a podcast I haven't done yet. I
haven't released yet with uh Mikuel
Parakin, who was the CTO of Shopify now,
but he was the uh guy leading Bing where
Sydney was uh the original sort of
unaligned chatbot that emerged. Uh but I
think people really have fun when when
your soul your chatbot has personality.
Your clanker uh you know has different
obsessions.
>> Well, it wasn't because it the world
changed, right? We had we had chat GBD
in 2023 and 4 and it was basically
us having AI without understanding what
AI can do. So we rebuilt a Google so you
have like a search field and like you
get a response and you you don't expect
Google to have a personality.
>> Yeah. But now that we moved more towards
agents, like if if I I didn't think
about in the beginning WhatsApp relay
and I just hooked it up to cloud code.
Um and then I when I was on WhatsApp, I
noticed that it doesn't feel quite
right. Like even even though like cloud
code already has some personality, it
didn't really fit how people would write
to you on WhatsApp. So that that's how
my whole iteration started was like uh
this again it's about taste, right? It
doesn't feel quite right. It's like too
wordy. It uses too many dots. It it it
my friends text different. And then
that's how I started working. They say,
"No, this isn't like try to write more
like a human."
>> Uh yeah, I I actually run a writing
>> like a lobster.
>> Uh like a lobster. Yes. Um
uh you know the one of my favorite
quotes of yours is uh madness with a
touch of sci science fiction. Yeah.
Right. Like that this is how you run
>> um uh AI projects. And I think
>> not all the art projects, but
specifically
something like OpenClaw would have never
been able, it would not have come out of
an American company just because it
would have been killed in legal long
before it would have been released
because it just has some problems that
we haven't really solved as an industry
yet.
>> Yeah.
>> But now we have some mitigations and
it's getting better. The models are
getting a lot better. But I don't see
how any of the big labs could have
released that. You know, it would be too
much push back. Oh, and like not enough
market proof that this is what people
want.
>> Yeah.
>> So like it had to be done by someone
>> like
>> outside. Yeah. That that that
>> sitting
>> like literally like when I when I built
it in the very beginning, I was like,
"Oh, what's the worst that can happen?"
like it could exfiltrate my token,
my emails. Yeah, nothing is nothing
nothing's in there that would like
completely kill me. You could like
upload some of my pictures. I was like,
yeah, I guess the worst are already
online if you use Grinder. Um,
so it was like it was like,
okay, I can live with that risk. It will
be uncomfortable, but it's like it's
manageable.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, if your company is a different it
requires a little different approach.
>> Yeah. By the way, uh his Instagram
account, good follow under
underfollowed.
It's also it's also has some good stuff.
Um okay. Uh you were talking about
WhatsApp, talking about Telegram. A lot
of these text apps. Um uh text apps are
good. People are also looking for like
the next form factor. People want like
the maybe the the glasses, the earbuds.
What What is your sort of wish list in
terms of having agents in your life?
I started on that actually already, but
then I was just getting bogged down by
all the people using it and just like
the daily grind.
But if you're at home, I want to be in
any room and you know at Star Trek when
you can when you say computer
I I I want to like talk to my agent
wherever I am and it should just be able
to like respond to me. It should know
where I am. I have like little iPads in
every room and and my agent can use the
canvas feature and project stuff on
those iPads. So like if I ask a question
that that is like easier to be to be
answered by also showing me something
like it could use like the nearest
display because it's aware of where I
am. So the phone is just a very
convenient input point but I kind of
want to like talk to it from anywhere.
Yeah.
>> Like yeah if I'm around and I have
glasses I should just like be able to
like listen in and like project
something on me.
>> Um
>> but just ubicular follow you
>> I think yeah once we have
>> really smart home. Yeah,
>> like agents on your phone, but really
you want ubiquitous agents and then you
want maybe you will have your your your
uppercase open claw your private agent
at work. You might have your I don't
know lowerase openi claw
and then
that claw should be able to like talk to
your personal claw uh in a way that both
your company and you are comfortable
with. So that's kind of like the future
where we need to work out.
>> Yeah. Uh one of uh I just did a podcast
with Maran Dre who's a huge fan uh and
and also uh have conversations with
Andre Karpathy. Both of these guys are
running OpenCloud to run their house.
And I think OpenClaw for homes is like a
kind of underrated, but like people are
really discovering it. And my funniest
sort of irony is that is it's only
possible because the internet of
means that most smart devices are
terrible in security, which means Open
Core can run them.
>> Oh, it's going to be able to work so
much better in in a few months when the
models are getting really bad.
>> Yeah, they're very good. Um, okay. One
security question. uh about prompt
injection. How do you want to solve
prompt injection or what what uh ways in
which uh have you been thinking about
the prompt injection problem?
Probably not enough yet. On the other
hand, like the the the front end models
are really quite good at detecting all
the
all the cases where like just stuff
randomly comes in from a website or an
email is usually not a problem anymore.
You mark as untrusted content, very hard
to excfiltrate you from that. If if I
have unlimited access to your claw and
can bombard it with stuff, then there's
still a chance.
>> Then then there's still a chance. But
like for one of things,
>> it's no longer the biggest problem. If
you use that's also why why you know
that this is probably the angle where
like some people say, "Oh, Peter doesn't
like local models." But then I see like
people running like a 20 uh billion
parameter model that just does whatever
you tell it and and it's not trained to
have any defenses at all. That's still
problematic. If you run that and then
you use a web browser or email um would
worry me. That's why that's why OpenClow
warns you if you use a small model. And
I know people spin the whole thing like
we hate model. I I love I love I love
that it we support everything, but like
you have to
steer
the regular user a little bit into a
direction to make it harder for them to
shoot themselves in the foot.
>> Um
yeah, there there is some ideas for
problem injection. It's
>> just a little bit away. I haven't
announced that.
>> I think Simon Willis has been working a
lot on on this. is I mean he coined the
term prompt injection and the sort of
dual LLM approach seems smart uh and I'm
I'm not smart enough to figure out all
the ways that which it can be attacked
like at at some point trust just has to
be a thing right um and uh and I pro
something interesting I found out from
talking with Vincent who's speaking next
is that you guys had to implement the
same trust system that Toby Luca had to
implement which is uh you build
reputation over time and things with
more trust uh gets more privileged
access, right? And I think that that
makes sense.
>> That's part of the story.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Um okay, so uh some
more broader questions. What cool
projects would you like to work on once
you have more free time?
>> I mean, I wanted to work on dreaming and
know like my maintenance worked on
dreaming while I I'm there like
>> while you were dreaming.
>> Uh so shift it, right?
>> Yes. What what is dreaming? Uh it's like
a way to reconcile memories and like
kind of create a little bit like like a
dream log go through like your session
logs. Um
>> we we found out from the enthropic
source code leak that they also working
on dreaming, right?
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. I mean there's
I'm pretty sure there's like more
companies working on that. But think a
little bit like how do we learn as
humans? You you experience a lot of
things during the day and then you sleep
and and in sleep your your brain does
like a garbage collect
converts some me some
local locally stored memories into
long-term storage and like drops others
and that that's similar ideas that I
think could also be very useful for
agents. Um and then like what we shipped
on dreaming is like the first little
step in that direction.
>> Yeah. It's related to the wiki uh thing
that Andre has been talking about where
you sort of collect everything into a
>> wiki is is more memory but like
everything kind of blends a little bit
together. Um that the beauty the beauty
of open claw is that we can just try
stuff you know like like everything what
we worked on for the last months or so
is that
in the beginning it was a big spaghetti
codebased mess and now like everything
everything is an extension a plug-in. So
you can replace memory, you can add the
wicki, you can add dreaming, you can add
I don't know your your your whatever
crazy idea you have and just make it
your own. You don't have to send
everything to a pull request because
we're still completely overloaded on
those. But it's it's more like Linux
where you just can install your own
parts.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And uh you are building what
a lot of people think uh is the most
consequential open source since Linux
which I don't know how do you deal with
that? How do you deal with the the the
fame what is a day in your life uh as as
the BDFL effectively of something like
this?
>> What's my Well, there's still a lot of
coding. There's also a lot of
>> by the way in in between sessions he was
coding
back there.
>> Yeah. They get tokenized. You have to
like something has to be right.
>> You have to push the agents, right?
>> Yeah. Um
where it shifted a little bit now it's a
lot more a lot more talking and
steering people in the right direction
like because there's a lot of things
that we already learned at Open Claw. So
like part of my role at OpenI is like to
like help them not make the same
mistakes again. Um
and then and then open claw is like try
out new things that seem exciting and
some might work and some might not work.
Enable enable companies to like build
their own claw without having to fork
away but like making everything more
more customizable. Um yeah and sometimes
I sleep sometimes you sleep. Okay great.
Uh I think that maybe this is the last
good closing questions. Uh, what skills
do you want humans and engineers in
particular to focus on developing in the
age of AI?
>> Taste was a big one, but I already
mentioned that
system design is still very important.
>> Yes, you we talked about this in San
Francisco. Yeah,
>> if you don't think about that, you will
eventually swipe yourself into a corner,
right? Just by defining the boundaries
like the funny thing is like everything
is in the clanker but you still need to
ask the right questions otherwise
that makes the difference of like good
code that comes out or like really bad
code that comes out and that's still
where like all the knowledge you have
like how you build software you can
apply to steer the agent into into
something that is not slop.
>> Yeah. And then I think I think a skill
that is becoming more and more important
is saying no.
And and and that's something I had to
learn as well because
even the wildest idea is just just a
prompt away.
And usually this one idea is never the
problem but like this idea and this idea
and this idea and this idea and then how
all of that fits together that's the
problem.
>> Yes. So like
I think we're still bottlenecked on
syncing and about like big picture
syncing because imagine the world from
your clanker like you're being thrown
into a code base. You might have an
outdated agent.md file, but you
basically don't know what DF this is and
you like then like you tell me, hey, add
user profiles and you like somehow add
user profiles and connect it to the two
things you see, but you didn't see the
whole system, right? And then that's
where a lot of those localized solutions
comes where like your project has like
vS and and it's our job to like help the
agent do its best work by like providing
them with like hints. Hey, you want to
consider this? You want to look there?
How would this interplay with this? And
then and then ultimately you get like a
much a system that actually is
maintainable.
>> Yeah. Um well, thank you for maintaining
one of the most important software of
all time and thank you for spending time
with us.
>> Thanks for having me.
>> Hopefully you stick around and answer
questions. Thank you.
>> All right.